congratulations are in order for nicki
minaj
[Music]
the 37 year old rapper just became a
proud mama
giving birth to her first child with
husband kenneth petty
it's one of the best feelings in the
world
[Music]
nikki announced she was expecting on
july 20th
with an instagram photo of herself
cradling her bear baby bump
and the caption preggers and i'm really
excited
i heard you recently got married
congratulations yeah minaj who's been
linked to petty since 2018
confirmed in october that they tied the
knot she later revealed
this about married life during an
appearance on lil wayne's
young money radio i didn't think it
would
be as refreshing and calming as it is
but it kind of you know when well and
you know even if you're not married just
when you have somebody that
that is feels like your soulmate or is
very understanding
understands you yeah it just makes you
feel like you're on top of the world
and while chatting with e.t at her fendi
prince on launch party in october
the singer explained how her wedding
plans changed after finding the one
when i was little i always imagined you
know princess and marriage and wedding
the wedding
and now it's more to me about
the the life the future the love the
partnership
than the wedding which is so strange
because i didn't expect myself to be one
of those people
who didn't care about the hoopla but i
really don't i just kind of feel like it
doesn't mean as much as it used to mean
because the other part the real part i
have it now and i'm so happy
plus nikki had this to say when asked
about the couple's plans
for expanding their family you talk
about the family
like how hard are we practicing right
now not to put you on the spot
you're practicing practice all the time
like
i'm just you know with the times of
night
okay but the thing is at first i was
like
i want to know when and now when it now
and then i started thinking
if i if i want it right right now or if
i want to wait like another year because
i have a couple things that i have to do
the
thing possibly possibly
well turns out those plans changed
once you fall in love with someone like
they'll always be your person
congratulations to nikki and kenneth
it's a big freaking deal
[Music]